hey everyone and welcome to biology  professor today i'm going to show you  how to use autoclave tape so autoclave  tape is some tape that starts out you  see these white lines that are on it and  you peel off some tape you put it on the  glassware that you are sterilizing in an  autoclave and if your autoclave run is  successful you'll see that those white  lines  have turned black so here's some beakers  and some i've got some tools wrapped in  aluminum i've got some tips here  here's some autoclave  some autoclave liquids that i did in a  previous run you see everywhere those  white lines have turned black and that  tells us  that the autoclave run was successful  and these things are now sterile so  thanks for watching biology professor  remember to subscribe bye